two one nine two david p is our  voicemail number here is feedback to our  interview with Richard Spencer the  alt-right white nationalist take a  listen  hey David this is Kevin from Louisiana I  just listened to your interview with  Richard Spencer and he might be one of  the most articulate morons  I've ever heard in my life he seemed to  be very confused between genetics a skin  color culture and religion couldn't seem  to tell the difference between either  one of those three anyway the other show  man yeah but the good work thank you  yeah  another one was educated neo-nazi was  another a bit of feedback to Richard  Spencer yes we I'm gonna talk tomorrow  more about the repercussions from that  interview there have been some I'm out  of time it's a great bonus show today  trust me folks  trust me david pakman.com slash  membership coupon code  I voted 17 if you'd like a discount